mr. Shapiro he talked about white
privilege and just this week I had a
conversation with Rachel Lazar who's
done some work a Jewish American woman
who's done some work on this area as
well as having extensive conversations
with dr. Greg parks of Wake Forest
University who's also talked quite a bit
about critical race theory and it's it's
my understanding that white privilege is
not telling individuals that they cannot
speak but it is a term for societal
privilege that individuals have as a
benefit of their white skin and I don't
think that and I think universities
would be remiss to then say that because
you're white you're not allowed to say
anything that's critical of white people
I didn't know that white privilege
actually went into that sphere my
understanding is it's just and the issue
is is that white privilege makes people
uncomfortable to talk about the societal
privilege that they have well it to me
the what I say on campuses all the time
is if you're want to cite instances of
racism that we can all find and fight
together that's something that I am more
than willing to stand next to you and
fight because that's obviously stuff
that we should fight together but when
you just say that there is a white
privilege out there in the ether and
that by dint of birth your skin color
generates for you an advantage what you
are really saying to people is that you
your view is less valuable because you
have not experienced what I've
experienced and that is an identity
argument that's a character argument
that's not a rational political argument
that can actually be be taken on in
anyway that's that's it's more of a it's
more of a cudgel
and a club than it is an attempt to open
a discussion well I think it's a
demonstrable evidence that through
society's demographics so that being
white has societal privileges that being
black does not but I we can talk because
I'm also interested in what you just
said now is that you would stand next to
anyone who has this so mr. Shapiro my
question to you is form is miss dump
stone the tying the noose around the
campus
messages that target african-american
young students would you consider that
hate speech in them would you stand next
to her and fight for her as I say it
would is the first I'm hearing about it
honestly but really what yeah but but
from from hearing about it maybe because
it's local and in from LA but in any
case um I'm more than happy more than
happy to stand alongside her and and
fight whatever group was responsible for
this know not only more than happy I
mean you're talking about the alright
again I was the number one target of an
systematic irassman from the alt-right
last year I'm more than happy to do all
that and I think there's one more
distinction that has to be made when we
talk about cases like like Taylor's
they're horrific and the administration
is siding with Taylor
okay the administration is doing the
right thing by Taylor or trying to do
the right thing
by Taylor as they should be and I think
that we need to make a distinction
between cases where the administration
is actively participating in the
suppression of speech in cases in which
the administration is trying to do the
right thing as is in order to in order
to make people in order to punish people
for application of crime